tchad le français christian maes libérés
arrivent demain paris - 14 en lozère 0
degrés à carpentras le printemps n'a
jamais autant ressemblé l'hiver première
conséquence est français à consommer
plus d'énergie qu'on ne l'aurait
souhaité comité directeur agitée chez
les radicaux de gauche michel crépeau
candidat à la présidence du mouvement
quittent la réunion
bonsoir il faut ajouter à ces titres que
vient de nous annoncer bernard rapp une
nouvelle fois la marée noire de bretagne
c'est maintenant le sud du finistère de
la pointe du raz au port de penmarc'h
qui sont directement menacées par la
pollution
heureusement pour l'instant le vent
vient du nord la rade de brest et la
baie de douarnenez sont épargnés mais
s'il tournait à l'ouest se vend ce
serait une nouvelle catastrophe nous
allons reparler de cette marée noire
dans quelques minutes à la fin du
journal avec un reportage de claude
carré et de françois granier sur l'île
de batz une île encerclé par le mazout
une enquête particulièrement
intéressante mais revenons aux premiers
titres de l'actualité de ce jour à
savoir la libération au nigeria des deux
otages des rebelles tchadiens
le français christian mas et le suisse
andré qu merlyn trois mois après leur
enlèvement les deux jeunes gens on
retrouvait donc leur liberté hier soir
quelque part près du lac tchad ce qui
les détenaient les ont remis apparemment
sans condition aux ambassadeurs de
france et de suisse au nigeria ils sont
revenus en avion dans la journée à lagos
la capitale
christian mas devrait être à paris
demain dans la journée
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing a
remercié le gouvernement nigérian pour
cette action qui est un exemple de ce
que doit être la coopération
internationale lorsqu'il s'agit d'
enlèvement ou deux prises d'otages qui
sont inacceptables
quelques puissent être les motifs
invoqués par leur auteur a dit le chef
de l'état
je propose d'écouter ce que christian
maes bien expliqué à nos confrères
d'europe 1 à propos des circonstances de
son enlèvement pour le lin on était plus
rennais on attendait une hausse de notre
chemin est encore long
côté avoir le t on aller avec au niveau
du lit où la vitesse et puis après bach
op rendu compte que beaucoup donc les
béliers et en grippe
leur micro on est étonné des autres puis
il m'a dit qu'il était en pleine forme
en très très bonne santé même il m'a dit
tu verras je suis bronzé et qu'il avait
été très très bien traités qu'ils
avaient participé à la vie des de ses
gardiens et qu'ils avaient toujours
cherché à savoir comment il pouvait
améliorer ses conditions de détention
aviez vous attendiez vous cette nouvelle
vient enfin un petit peu oui parce que
nous savions qu'une action était en
cours et on attendait enfin tant que
vous n'avez pas la nouvelle est bien
c'est ça a été long vous ressenti en
apprenant beaucoup de soulagement
ah oui un énorme soulagement
l'angoissent kit déco disparaît et puis
une joie enfin c'est pas tellement c'est
pas traduisible en mots c'est céline
laventure de christian maes avait
commencé dans cette région du lac tchad
à la frontière du nigeria
le 18 janvier dernier une simple étape
dans son voyage autour de l'afrique à 20
ans christian maes étudiant en maths
veut en effet voir du pays il a décidé
de suspendre ses études pendant un an
après le maroc l'algérie et le niger
il veut se rendre au cameroun en passant
par le lac tchad et trouver du travail à
yaoundé la région n'est pas sûr
christian maes ne sait il est pourtant
emmenés par les rebelles avec son
compagnon de voyage
le suisse andré que mr lips les rebelles
se réclament du front de libération
nationale du tchad une branche parallèle
à celle qui a détenu françoise claustré
pendant trois ans
investi au nord du pays christian maes
est accusée d'espionnage pour sa
libération laerdal demande 10 millions
de francs des armes et le départ du
tchad des 600 hommes du corps
expéditionnaire français deux fois il
menace d'exécuter et christian maes et
son compagnon
mais ces rebelles sont représentés dans
l'état voisin le nigeria après deux mois
de contacts diplomatiques et à
l'occasion d'un voyage de deux jours au
nigeria
monsieur 2ghz 1go annonça la mère de
christian maes que son fils sera bientôt
près d'elle merci qu'il est proche ou
encore beaucoup d'inquiétude ce soir
pour les cinq jeunes alpinistes
parisiens bloqués dans les pyrénées
espagnoles depuis mercredi dernier par
le mauvais temps depuis trois jours
l'une des membres du groupe et au fond
d'une crevasse où elle est tombée
l'un de ses compagnons a réussi à la
rejoindre mais depuis la situation a peu
évolué en particulier à cause de la
tempête de neige qui continue de
souffler sur les pyrénées ce matin
pendant une accalmie un hélicoptère a pu
déposer deux sauveteurs de gendarmes
mais la colonne de secours qui étaient
partis vers les alpinistes en difficulté
a dû rebrousser chemin dans la soirée à
cause du mauvais temps
conditions atmosphériques déplorables
également dans le vercors où une
opération de secours a été lancée pour
retrouver une institutrice de grenoble
disparu depuis vendredi
demain l'amélioration du temps prévu par
les spécialistes de la météo devrait
aider les sauveteurs
il y aura du soleil en particulier dans
l'après midi mais dans l'ensemble les
températures seront encore très froides
pour la saison
la liste de ces méfaits de ce printemps
aux couleurs d'hiver est bien longue
de la neige un peu partout en france
dans le sud le centre l'est du pays
du verglas bien évidemment du vent et de
la tempête en provence par exemple le
mois d'avril n'a jamais été aussi froid
depuis plus de 30 ans le vent a soufflé
en tempête jusqu'à 130 kilomètres à
l'heure le mistral a arraché des câbles
électriques sur la voie ferrée marseille
paris et certains trains ont été
retardés de deux heures froidure à
l'extérieur égale chauffage à
l'intérieur dans les maisons j'entends
équation est bien connu lipsky a donc
demandé un responsable de l'edf quelles
pouvaient être les répercussions de ce
printemps hivernale
sur la consommation d'énergie chiffres
ont d'ailleurs assez précisément cette
consommation supplémentaire les de
l'ordre de 350 1000 kilowatts par degré
de froid or comme actuellement nous
avons une température moyenne de l'ordre
de 8 degrés en dessous de la moyenne
normale pour la saison
c'est vous dire l'importance éléments de
cette consommation supplémentaire alors
les économies qu'on pouvait attendre par
exemple du changement d'heure d'hiver en
heure d'été sont pratiquement annulé par
ce froid c'est à dire que les économies
importée par le changement d'heure d'été
subsistent mais en effet elles sont
hélas largement compensé même au delà
très au delà
par ce froid tout à fait inattendu et
exceptionnel c'est une consommation du
mois d'avril qui se peut se comparer à
consommation de calmants en hiver c'est
assez comparable à la consommation du
mois de janvier
on peut craindre des coupures et des
interruptions non je pense que nous
avons toutes les chances de passer sans
nouvelles coupures le jour les semaines
à venir et le et le reste le bas mais
également le mauvais temps en italie
également responsable sans doute de la
catastrophe ferroviaire qui s'est
produite cet après midi près de bologne
les pluies de ces derniers jours d'après
les enquêteurs auraient provoqué un
glissement de terrain qui a causé
l'accident d'un convoi rapide qui venait
de rome il a débouché à pleine vitesse
après une ligne droite dans libouli qui
était sur la voie
la locomotive et les wagons ont déraillé
un autre train qui arrivait en sens
inverse j'avais plein fouet les
sauveteurs ce soir sont encore en train
de dégager les victimes
le bilan provisoire pour l'instant est
de 50 morts et d'une centaine de blessés
la politique maintenant en france ce
week-end c'est essentiellement le comité
directeur du mouvement des radicaux de
gauche et d'après ce que m'a expliqué
daniel brel cela ne s'est pas passé très
bien cet après midi on a vu s'affronter
en particulier deux hommes candidats à
la présidence et deux tendances
michel crépeau soutenu parce qu'ils sont
plus proches des socialistes et monsieur
maroselli accusé de vouloir recoller les
morceaux des deux partis radicaux voilà
le compte rendu des débats du comité
directeur
mini tempête en effet cet après midi
dans les rangs des radicaux de gauche
michel crépeau celui de ses amis a
quitté brusquement la tribune et la
salle pour marquer son désaccord
il refusait de s'associer à une motion
présentée par les amis de ma rose et
textos rendre hommage à l'action menée
pendant cinq ans par le président
démissionnaire robert fin pour michel
crépeau c'était accepter sans le dire
que le émerger quitte l'union de la
gauche il récusait à la fois le fond et
la procédure vous allez l'entendre
alors certains la sauver nous référant
mis en gage dans le brouhaha le
président de séance le sénateur pas
minimiser l'incident affirmant qu'il y
avait accord de tous sur les objectifs
l'accent a été mis sur la nécessité pour
le moment les rivaux de gauche
il a retrouvé sa propre personnalité de
revenir nous mêmes sans variation
d'orientation c'est à dire toujours à
gauche avec une personnalité raffermit
la vitalité du mouvement n'est pas à
démontrer
ces petits gecina auquel vous venez
d'assister ensemble de témoignages et
nous repartirons tous dans l'unité tu es
pas la première fois
nous continuons dans l'actualité de
cette fin de semaine l'un des événements
les plus marquants a été sans aucun
doute la proposition faite par le
sénateur caillavet à propos du droit à
la mort en cas de maladie incurable pour
vous permettre d'avoir une opinion plus
précise à ce sujet vous savez que jean
pierre elkabbach et martine allain
regnault avait réuni autour d'eux dans
notre magazine samedi et demi
aujourd'hui donc un certain nombre de
spécialistes et de témoin
particulièrement important parmi eux
bien entendu l'auteur de la proposition
monsieur key avait lui même je propose
de réécouter la réponse qu'il a faite au
père patrick verspieren je ne crois pas
que une loi telle que celle qui
proposait à monsieur caillavet résolve
le problème la loi du sénateur cavaliers
remplace cette concertation par un
papier
eh bien monsieur 1 bat pied ne parle pas
mais galope
permettez que je m'adresse à vous voulez
avec moi de le dire que ce qui compte
c'est la liberté du malade
car en effet ni à de dignité que dans la
liberté
il n'ya de liberté que par la conscience
lorsque de mon vivant en plein état de
conscience et de lucidité
je me refuse à l'acharnement
thérapeutique convenait que mon corps
m'appartient et n'appartient qu'à moi
il n'appartient à personne et pas
davantage au docteur et à un docteur je
ne peux donner que les droits qui
m'appartiennent et lui ne peut pas avoir
plus de droits que je lui en compte
et je n'accepte pas que au prétexte de
partenaires à une caste un certain
nombreux médecins s'érigerait dans ces
conditions un tribunal et de dire je
poursuis je ne profite pas ils ont le
droit pour tous ceux qui ne disent rien
mais pour celui qui le veut
c'est d'ailleurs celui qu'ils exigent en
tout lucide et de l'esprit jeudi que le
médecin doit se plier au droit que lui
impose son patient qu'elle était encore
ces quelques télégrammes rapide
un papa heureux et soulagé andré du
l'ont acquitté par le juge canadien de
vancouver
on avait été accusée d'avoir enlevé sa
fille est lucienne de cinq ans c'est une
manoeuvre de la mer a dit le juge vous
garderez votre enfant
quarante huit heures de brainstorming
pour le président carter et ses proches
collaborateurs une sorte de tempête sous
un crâne version américaine pour savoir
ce qui ne va pas dans l'administration
carter critiquer autant pour sa
politique extérieure que pour sa
politique intérieure la réunion le
séminaire commence demain à camp david
chili le général pinochet et vient de
nommer un nouveau gouvernement - deux
militaires plus de civils laissant aux
prisonniers politiques chiliens qui
seront exilés dans les prochains jours
ne pourront sans doute pas s'apercevoir
des changements en tennis mauvais
service de l'américain gerulaitis il a
été battu par le mexicain ramirez en
demi finale des internationaux de monte
carl ramirez rencontrera en finale le
tchèque smid football dernier match
aller des quarts de finale de la coupe
de france ce soir bastia reçoit monaco
résultat dans le dernier journal
présenté par bernard rapp et puis retour
à la marée noire maintenant avec valéry
giscard d'estaing qui poursuit d'abord
ses vacances avec sa famille à
courchevel et avec le mauvais temps
valéry giscard d'estaing a décidé de se
rendre donc prochainement en bretagne
sur les côtes sinistrée par le pétrole
de la moto club
100 c'est que la bretagne est prêt à les
inculper le chef de l'état a fait une
déclaration hier après le ski en
rencontrant 80 jeunes bretons du canton
de portsall invités à courchevel par la
station monsieur vers les riches valéry
giscard d'estaing également parlé du
problème de la prévention de la
pollution
le premier problème il faut savoir c'est
un problème international c'est la
fixation des routes sur lesquelles
circulent de ces grands pétroliers ils
vont éloigner ces routes des copies de
façon à se disent tiens un navire est en
difficulté il ne risque pas de heurter
un récif où un rocher on ait le temps
d'aller le chercher et de corriger son
avarie peut donc éloigner les routes des
côtes c'est la première chose mais c'est
un accord international
il est très important que nous ayons la
plus de neuf partenaires pour aborder en
commun cette négociation internationale
il faut ensuite alors sur place
naturellement les moyens de porter
secours à un navire en difficulté et les
moyens également d'intervenir si un
navire ne respectent pas les règles de
navigation et notre marine nationale
sera doté de ses moyens enfin il faut
mettre fin à des pratiques abusives
concernant le non respect des règles de
sécurité ou d'équipement sur un certain
nombre de navires et nous proposerons
que l'accès des ports européens soit
interdit aux navires qui ne respectent
pas un certain nombre de normes de
sécurité
mais s'ils ne peuvent pas avoir accès au
port de ce fait ils sont écartés des
obligations et ils sont amenés à
respecter définitivement cirque
enfin j'estime que si l'on met en
application l'ensemble de ces règles si
l'on veille très strictement à la
surveillance nous devons éliminer ce
risque pour la bretagne et pour l'heure
monnet métier vous aimons faire ces
vieilleries culteurs il a demandé si
j'allais un hommage et j'ai dit oui à
parler de la bretagne est resté à
l'accident quand tu l'as trouvé le
président à propos de cette marée noire
de l'amoco cadiz que par la conscience
lorsque de mon vivant plein état de
conscience et de lucidité
je me refuse à l'acharnement
thérapeutique convenait que mon corps
m'appartient et n'appartient qu'à moi
qui n'appartient à personne et pas
davantage ce docteur est à un docteur je
ne peux donner que les droits qui
m'appartiennent et lui ne peut pas avoir
plus de droits que je lui confère et je
n'accepte pas que au prétexte par tenir
à une caste un certain nombre de
médecins s'érigerait dans ces conditions
en tribunal et de dire je poursuis je ne
profite pas ils ont le droit pour tous
ceux qui ne disent rien mais pour celui
qui le veut c'est d'ailleurs celui
qu'ils exigent en toute lucidité
d'esprit je dis que le médecin doit se
plier au droit que lui impose son
patient qu'elle était encore ces
quelques télégrammes rapide
un papa heureux et soulagé andré du
l'ont acquitté par le juge canadien de
vancouver
on l'avait accusée d'avoir enlevé sa
fille est lucienne de cinq ans c'est une
manoeuvre de la mer a dit le juge vous
garderez votre enfant
quarante huit heures de brainstorming
pour le président carter et ses proches
collaborateurs une sorte de tempête sous
un crâne version américaine pour savoir
ce qui ne va pas dans l'administration
carter critiquer autant pour sa
politique extérieure que pour sa
politique intérieure la réunion le
séminaire commence demain à cordes
habite chili le général pinochet vient
de nommer un nouveau gouvernement - deux
militaires plus de civils laissant aux
prisonniers politiques chiliens qui
seront exilés dans les prochains jours
ne pourront sans doute pas s'apercevoir
des changements en tennis mauvais
service de l'américain gerulaitis il a
été battu par le mexicain ramirez en
demi finale des internationaux de monte
carl ramirez rencontrera en finale le
tchèque smid football dernier match
aller des quarts de finale de la coupe
de france ce soir bastia reçoit monaco
résultat dans le dernier journal
présenté par bernard ap et puis retour à
la marée noire maintenant avec valéry
giscard d'estaing qui poursuit d'abord
ses vacances avec sa famille à
courchevel et avec le mauvais temps
valéry giscard d'estaing a décidé de se
rendre donc prochainement en bretagne
sur les côtes sinistrée par le pétrole
de la moto pensait que la grosse scène
est prêt à les accuser le chef de l'état
a fait cette déclaration hier après le
ski en contrant 80 jeunes bretons du
canton de portsall alité à courchevel
par la station monsieur vers dirige
valéry giscard d'estaing également parlé
du problème de la prévention de la
pollution
le premier problème il faut savoir c'est
un problème international c'est la
fixation des routes sur lesquelles
circulent le segment pétrolier ils vont
éloigner ces routes d'écoles de passons
à ce qui suit un navire est en
difficulté il ne risque pas de se
heurter un récit pour un rocher on ait
le temps d'aller le chercher et de
corriger son avarie peut donc éloigner
les routes des côtes c'est la première
chose mais c'est un accord international
il est très important que nous ayons la
plus de neuf partenaires pour aborder en
commun cette négociation internationale
il faut ensuite alors sur place
naturellement les moyens de porter
secours à un navire en difficulté et les
moyens également d'intervenir si un
navire ne respectent pas les règles de
navigation et notre marine nationale
sera doté de ses moyens enfin il faut
mettre fin à des pratiques abusives
concernant le non respect des règles de
sécurité ou d'équipement sur un certain
nombre de navires et nous proposerons
que l'accès des ports européens soit
interdit aux navires qu'ils ne
respectent pas un certain nombre de
normes de sécurité
et s'ils peuvent pas avoir accès au port
de ce fait ils sont écartés de la
navigation et ils sont amenés à
respecter définitivement céreq 20
j'estime que si l'on met en application
l'ensemble de ces règles si l'on veut
très strictement à la surveillance nous
devons éliminer ce risque pour la
bretagne et pour l'heure
maudit je m'étais posé mon père c'est
bien lecteurs il a demandé si j'allais
au g10 ni parler de la bretagne est
resté à l'accident il a trouvé le
président à propos de cette marée noire
de l'amoco cadiz
on vous a beaucoup parlé de technique et
de chiffres ces derniers jours des
milliers de tonnes de pétrole méthodes
employées pour nettoyer les conséquences
économiques avec le reportage que nous
allons vous présenter maintenant claude
carré et françois granier ont voulu
surtout vous expliquer comment une
communauté bretonne
les habitants de l'île de batz comment
ils vivent cette catastrophe ça
reportage d'une longueur un peu
inhabituel pour un journal télévisé
mais c'est surtout un reportage qui
permet parfaitement de comprendre
l'ampleur de la catastrophe
c'est le seul lien avec le continent la
vedette qui plusieurs fois par jour fait
la navette entre roscoff et l'île de
batz une île minuscule 7 kilomètres
carrés à une demi-heure de traverser
tout vient de la côte le ravitaillement
l'équipement les touristes
tout repart vers la côte la pêche le
goémon les primeurs
ce
oui
toute l'île vie de la mère mais
aujourd'hui la mer l'empoisonnent
depuis la catastrophe les 32 bateaux de
lille ne sont plus sortis la dernière
pêche polluer jeter le matériel est hors
d'usagé
deux cents personnes sont sans travail
touchera c'est fini passées ces patrons
savent alors la meilleure saison pour
nous elle est priée de jarinje des
trappes
on a beau dire ce n'est les araignées
qui rapport le mieux pour nous vous l
impression que les clients ne veulent
plus acheter de quoi son coût 3 août au
matin j'ai envoyé des arts ina et à la
maison d'armé essonne et a pris le temps
que je suis jolie roi
les travailleurs quoi partir de lille
vincent meylan vie j'essaie de ne pas
travailler et aller où nous promet des
sous là mais c'est pas quand qu'ils vont
venir en plus une loi qui vient de
prendre des bateaux là cette année là ça
fait deux morts les rembourser pas tous
mais on ne peut pas pêcher
elle s'en va faire pas su voir un filet
comme ça c'est ses soixante-dix mille un
fils de 50 mètres revient km 5
tu dois en tirer tout ça
la saison sera finie aussi groupe
au 12e jour après la catastrophe
première visite des responsables du plan
polmar l'île pose des problèmes
particuliers il faut acheminer des
moyens de nettoiement et évacué sur le
continent les résidus de cette marée
noire qui concerne les îliens
l'île de batz plonge son étrave de plage
et de rochers dans la nappe de mazout
qui dérivent du lieu de la catastrophe à
35 kilomètres de là vers le large
exposé à tous les vents lille est cernée
par le mazout
pour accéder aux plages les bulldozer
détruise la langue saccage nécessaire
qui meurtrit un peu plus et accroît
l'amertume de cette île tranquille
le cheval du goémoniers est au repos son
maître au chômage le goémon polluer ne
sera pas ramassés
plus nombreux les jeunes partiront cette
année faire la campagne sucrière dans le
nord de la france les exploitations
agricoles de deux ou trois acteurs ne
permettent pas seul de joindre les deux
bouts
dix mois sur douze l'île vit modestement
810 habitants l'hiver 3500 l'été mais
maintenant les touristes boudent guilde
nation je vois pour le week-end de
pâques par exemple bombe sur les
nominations bon on en avait huit de
prises et nec 2 4 personnes ça fait pas
beaucoup
j'ai l'impression que là vous allez
rater la saison touristique
non il faut pas être pessimiste je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de problème tout va être
nettoyé déjà ou voyez comment que tout
le monde s'y emploie et je pense que ça
devrait aller quand même
et
oh
n'allons pas accuser le seigneur
seigneur ne pas voulu cette marée noire
pas plus qu'il ne l'a voulu qui ne veut
la guerre lallouet se fait
malheureusement le seigneur nous venons
de le chanter est bon et ils ne peuvent
pas se servir de ces choses là pour nous
punir comme on dit car s'il y a une
marée noire
eh bien c'est la faute des hommes c'est
parce que les hommes n'ont pas pris ici
ou là où il aurait dû les prendre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pris les mesures
nécessaires pour éviter cela sur 12
n'accusons pas le seigneur
et
m
pas chez avec le ciel furieux contre les
hommes ils ont manifesté au pc du plan
polmar pour qu'on ne les oublie pas
conscience et puis les gens et je sais
pas ils se sont révoltés intérieurement
et même je me suis je suis allé en lui
les crêtes pour port et ben il fallait
une étincelle suffirait pour hansen mais
tous
une compagnie du 7e chasseurs d'arras
des barges de débarquement de la marine
des tonnes à lisier des pompes ont été
acheminés va et vient incessant entre
l'île et le continent moyens dérisoires
et traditionnelles bonne volonté et
bricolage le mazout s'est infiltré dans
le sable ce sont maintenant des tonnes
de pétrole d'eau de sable et de cailloux
qu'il faut évacuer les coquillages sont
morts les poissons douteux les oiseaux
enfui je pense qu'on doit faire une
différence entre les communes comme nous
ils sont sinistrées à 100% et d'autres
communes moins sinistré que nous parce
que s'il y aura tout un équipement à
refaire nos routes
nous nous voie d'accès nous nous points
dont vous voyez enfin c'est un des deux
gros problème que nous aurons à débattre
dans l'avenir nous souhaitons que de
pareilles catastrophes ne se
reproduisent plus près la côte d'azur
oui
travail fastidieux à chaque marée
recommencer qui nécessite une longue
patience nous ramanou le mazout sait
rien de la petite balade parle en mon
pouvoir pour les prendre on ne sait pas
si c'est difficile de dire pour combien
de temps encore une chose est certaine
ce sera très long
enfin avec on remarque aussi que
le bas tout le monde sait que ce pétrole
est fluide et que quand même là bas si
c'est la marque qui va finir le boulot
pour le
reportage de claude carré et de françois
granier vers 23h20 bernard rapp loin de
la fièvre du samedi soir avec son calme
et sa compétence habituelle vous
présentera la dernière édition du
journal
je vous retrouve demain à 13h et je vous
souhaite une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2